J'avais l'habitude d'écouter les gens demander de l'
aide, c'est ce que j'essayais de faire, c'est d'
aider les gens,
mais je me trompais. L'obscurité ne
répond qu'à l'obscurité.
m'a changé qu'est-ce que tu
dis je veux faire un marché
qu'il prétend avoir changé et ils
ne le connaissent pas comme moi la dernière fois
que nous nous sommes parlé tu m'as menacé c'est
quelque chose que je ne peux rien nous
pardonner  bon cette fois ce n'est qu'une
façon de m'arrêter mais tu vas le faire
tu en es sûr fais
juste attention à ne pas devenir
le monstre parce que j'ai essayé de faire de cette
ville un meilleur endroit
pour dire au monde qui tu es vraiment
quelqu'un qui montre maintenant ses vraies
couleurs
parfois vous devez vous accrocher à précieux
c'est un plus grand bien
qu'il ait besoin d'un nouveau méchant je pense que je l'
aurais peut-être trouvé le casse-cou est notre
vrai public et
selon des témoins oculaires l'
attaque brutale a été un
casse
-cou êtes-vous je suis  casse-cou
vous